miranda lambert is getting personal  after this photo of she and boyfriend  anderson east caused a social media stir  the country singer shared this proud  moment on instagram noting she's wearing  yoga pants and no makeup on the back of  her horse in the reflective post  she writes last night i was all dolled  up and out on the town with my sweet man  i was excited about the night and posted  a picture just now when i looked i  realized so many comments were  judgmental and negative cowardly people  hiding behind a keyboard or a cell phone  writing their useless comments about our  eyes and clothes and body language what  a bunch of [ __ ]  yeah i mean i'm insecure about million  things just like every other girl but  you know i found that um i try not to  just get wrapped up in it after her  divorce from blake shelton and 2015  lambert started dating singer anderson  east that December the stunning pair hit  the carpet on Wednesday night in  matching black ensembles  you